[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is John
and koi genre here at the beautiful IMAX
HQ in Playa Vista California and we just
got done seeing Transformers rise of the
beast but before we talk about that just
want to say a huge thank you to the
folks at IMAX for having us out if you
follow this Channel at all you know that
IMAX is pretty much our favorite way to
see most any movie in a movie like this
at the scale it exists on is absolutely
the peak experience so if you got an
IMAX near you go see Transformers rise
of the beasts at an IMAX theater if it's
in IMAX I see it and I'm actually the
point where I have to schedule my
tickets ahead of time to catch it that's
sweet sweet IMAX week so see it in IMAX
absolutely sir and also before we hop
into the review leave a like leave a
like for Greg Greg is busy at home
slaving away on an emergency edit
otherwise he would have been here and I
mean he missed a lot because they
actually not only did we see the movie
Peter Cullen showed up did a q a it was
a lovely and then stayed after to hang
out absolutely absolutely he did but
anyway Transformers rise of the beasts
seventh live-action Transformers Motion
Picture how does it shape up well let's
talk about that neither of us is a huge
expert on the vast lore that these
stories come with that these characters
come with we got a lot to talk about and
before we do just gonna give a brief
synopsis of the film I'm so prepared hey
how's it going
just keeping everything on track right
now
I love carrots
Optimus Prime and the Autobots take on
their biggest challenge yet when a new
threat capable of destroying the entire
planet emerges they must team up with a
powerful faction of Transformers known
as the maximals to save Earth beautiful
nice Cameo Your Best Peter Cullen voice
yeah that's actually a pretty sure way
to describe the movie A lot of it takes
place in the 1990s taking place after
the events of Bumblebee Loosely
acknowledging that as you know part of
its immediate Canon and I know what
you're all first and foremost Champion
to hear about the Transformers across
this movie are gorgeous to look at as
always and there are a whole bunch of
different kinds because not only do you
have the Autobots but you also have the
maximals coming into play and the terror
cons the Agents of the god-being Unicron
who is essentially like the Galactus of
this universe yeah I love that parallel
during the group there was a lot of like
space Cosmic comic stuff and I was like
oh they're going there absolutely and
things that do sort of remind you of
certain other especially like DC kind of
movies visually and aesthetically and
even voice absolutely yeah and and
obviously Optimus Prime is you know the
sort of central Transformer but I think
the the character who really stole the
show this time around was Pete Davidson
as Mirage you know dressed in this
beautiful Porsche packaging I'm a
Porsche guy so I got a kick out of that
but what did you think of a mirage made
me so happy I was thinking the entire
time I don't want to realize who this is
because I'm having so much joy not
knowing and then when it was Pete
Davidson I was like of course it was
absolutely I really think he nailed the
I have to be somehow the new Bumblebee
without being bumblebee but also in a
movie with Bumblebee and a movie that
will also be Optimus Prime Centric like
that's a lot of things to joke you have
to be inherently Charming in small doses
you have to be charismatic in a really
unique way you have to be something
that's new to the franchise but also
familiar it's a really tall order and I
think delivered I really think the bond
between our humans and especially Mirage
was uniquely strong in this particular
installment of the Transformers yeah
absolutely and it certainly brings that
sort of endearing quality that your
human main character bonding with him so
he's kind of filling the Bumblebee role
even though bumblebee does appear in
this movie certainly Mirage is like your
your most chummy Autobot on the team and
then obviously you've got Peter Cohen
reprising the role of Optimus Prime and
and this is still very much sort of his
fight it's an ensemble it's an ensemble
piece of these Transformers but a lot of
it does still center around his journey
and his growth as a character we it's a
bit of an edgier take on Optimus Prime
because he is burdened with a lot of
remorse and just the weight of his
decisions in the parts of this war that
have you know affected everything up
until now and it's before he's had a lot
of time to spend with Humanity he hasn't
had the humanity he hasn't been endeared
to us which I really like that take so
the Rough Around the Edges had purpose
it wasn't just like edgy prime it was
like this is a guy who doesn't yet know
what he's dealing with on this planet in
a personal level which I enjoyed yeah
yeah yeah and I mean neither of us is
like a great Transformers expert
necessarily but there are times when you
can tell Maybe maybe certain lines of
dialogue in certain installments maybe
don't ring true and here I thought the
the times where they did flirt with the
line of you know what his character's
supposed to be what the essence is
supposed to be it did serve that sort of
challenge to his principles and and his
growth as a character so I thought yeah
it was mostly appropriately done and
then we have the character of Optimus
primal as well the sort of head maximal
these descendants of the Autobots that
have been all through time and space and
are now you know joining the fight here
in the present moment there's a lot of
timey ones in the store show Absolutely
from Beast Wars which Beast Wars is
probably my best Touchstone for
Transformers but I can tell you got uh
so I mean and a lot of people are
looking forward to the maximals first
and foremost from this movie how did you
feel about them I was so enamored by the
physicality I was so enamored by the
fact that it's hard enough to make a
Transformer look like it's tangible in
our world it's even harder to make a
Transformer look like it has authentic
animal physicality but also is a machine
that also has authentic textures it's a
lot of brilliant Computing like the
first Transformers I really think as
much as people don't look back on it as
fondly uh because of like the six movies
we've gotten through it doesn't feel as
novel anyway like there's not a novelty
to Transformers that first one was
mind-blowing seeing those special
effects seeing those pyrotechnics seeing
the baehem that was a mind-blowing
experience this was that for these
creatures this was just as mind-blowing
me there's a scene and it's not a
spoiler at all but there's a scene where
you see Beast Wars side by side with
humans side by side with cars and if
you'd just taken out the cars it would
look like a cartoon that looked photo
real but if you just take out the Beast
it looks like a car ad like it's all of
your brain going like I've seen this
before but I haven't seen it but I have
seen it and it was this really beautiful
suspension of disbelief blending all
these worlds and I really bought it in a
really fun way yeah absolutely I did too
and you know they aren't the most
heavily featured characters in terms of
dialogue and skin screen time but their
impression is definitely felt and they
definitely do take advantage of that
sort of mix between you know the more
organic animal shapes and then you know
the train Transformers car mechanics
they bring a nice new flavor to it as do
the the terracons who are sort of your
main villains LED mainly by Scourge who
I didn't even realize yeah who's he's
kind of the Steppenwolf of this movie
and I really think it worked I really
think this landed with not only Menace
but you're intrigued by him as the
character evolves you want to know more
I think that the franchise overall this
is the seventh one of these I think the
first one is the bar that said I think
the first one is unique and I think it
really is what people wanted a
Transformers movies live action and then
I think they've kind of strayed from
that path like they took certain notes
and went really aggressively one way or
the other I feel like they've had to
Chip Away back down to something
contained and I feel like this in
bumblebee are the most authentic two
Transformers we've had yeah because I
mean this has all the action and the
Carnage and the cool stuff that you want
but it also comes with I think the right
sort of cheese yeah like whenever it
dipped into cheese or haminess it was
always in a way that put a big smile on
my face and that brought me back to the
spirit of you know just playing with
action figures and being a kid in the
90s and there are certain only tons of
90s just pop culture Spanish characters
soundtrack my favorite character in this
movie is the 90s soundtrack absolutely
the soundtrack is so good it's a great
throwback and it definitely puts you in
the time and place and yeah I mean music
is absolutely transportive that way but
I thought what they chose was nicely
handled and I thought this movie did a
nice job of acknowledging that debating
that and you know even though it is kind
of silly having humans involved still
justifying it with enough I don't know
just reason to suit the kind of movie
that it is and it led to some really fun
moments with the human cast which is led
by uh Anthony Ramos and Dominique
Fishback who are both great like this is
a movie that doesn't heavily capitalize
on like the dramatic side of the human
stuff but it does give you enough to
care about with them they are very
charismatic and and they take the roles
just seriously enough this isn't my
favorite franchise this is my favorite
movie this summer but what I want out of
a Transformers movie this was so if you
love Transformers you're going to love
this if you don't love trying
Transformers you might not love this but
it is what it promises and I think
there's an inherent 80s Nostalgia 90s
Nostalgia joy that is very unique to
this franchise and this is playing The
Equalizer of that very beautifully yeah
absolutely and I mean people were going
off about like what's the shortest
Transformers movie yet and I mean it's
not that short of a movie yeah but it
does clip along in a way that does not
over bear on you too much and that does
maintain that level of fun and yeah that
throwback quality that makes you feel
like you're a kid and I mean the action
certainly you're coming to Transformers
for an action movie for beautiful
visuals and crazy Contraptions and
whatnot it's not like the most
everything is a money shot Michael based
style but there are certainly beautiful
sequences that take advantage of the
Sci-Fi and then there are sequences that
ground you nicely in you know the bits
of the human Stakes we do check in with
there are a lot of really good
supporting characters and the voice cast
you know I didn't necessarily always you
know it's like Ron Perlman is Optimus
primal he does a fantastic job for the
time he is there I maybe wanted a little
bit more of that Michelle yo is air
razor who's probably the most heavily
featured of the maximals even more I
mean in terms of screen time than
Optimus primal but she does a fine job
in her role Peter Dinklage is Scourge
which I had no idea about and there are
a couple other really fun voices mixed
into the cast uh for the I mean your
main Autobot team is Optimus Bumblebee
Mirage and RC but you do get a few other
Autobots as well as maximals and
terracons in the mix chitars in here the
whole thing kind of culminates in a
really fun adventure that has again all
the Transformers lore stuff that you
want and it's more focused on that while
giving enough create it's kind of like a
Godzilla movie it gives enough Credence
to his human characters that you can
endear to them I agree and I think the
pacing was one of its strengths I think
it's going to be good for kids that are
discovering the franchise as well as
people that have loved it for 40 years
honestly this was uh kind of a greatest
hits recall I really think this is
launching a franchise in a really
beautiful way I think it allows for us
to go forward while acknowledging the
past which I want our equals to do but
it does feel like a new world in a
really beautiful way and I'm very
optimistic about the future of the
Transformers because of this movie yeah
and there are a couple big surprises
toward the end that we cannot talk about
whatsoever at the internet but you
should avoid the internet and they're
absolutely so I'm very excited to see
what the response is because it's
something that I had no idea to even
think about yeah but yeah ultimately
just overall feelings what would you say
I'd say number one or two of the
franchise I think uh I think right up
there with the first one on bumblebee
like I think uh you know Transformers
one uh bumblebee in this are all at
another level and I think I was really
impressed with Anthony Ramos and I was
really impressed with the directing I
was really impressed with the world
built and I love the almost guy and and
his dog story that is the Transformers I
feel like there's always this like
companionship that translate between
Transformers then their human element
that they really captured well here so
it's able to manage uh like a really
good equalizer of all my favorite
elements of Transformers in a very
unique recoil that feels like it's
launching a franchise while giving some
love to the past and I I think that's a
really good place for the Transformers
to be right now yeah yeah it clipped
right along it has my favorite car uh
the skyline is in here there's a Nissan
Skyline r34j ADM Edition which is the
car that Brian drives in Fast and the
Furious and the color scheme of the
Porsche is the same color scheme as
brian's skyline so I had a lot of Fast
and Furious Love happening also RC is
Ducati was my favorite motorcycles they
have good taste in vehicles there's a
lot of beautiful Machinery on display
from Cars to bikes to planes to
otherwise and yeah it's the kind of
movie where it works more than it
doesn't and even when it is teetering on
Being Cheesy or hammy or whatever it is
again in a way that put a big smile on
my face and that I enjoyed from front to
back which is kind of all you can ask
for from one of these movies did not
outstay its welcome definitely gave me
those Thrills great use of setting too
between the New York scenes there's some
stuff that takes place in Peru and other
parts of the world and uh and yeah it
got me optimistic I would come back and
watch more of this version of
Transformers so I am Optimus Mystic
myself Adam Optimist Prime optimistic it
used to be that was my nickname a lot of
time not anymore Madam Terror John this
is the first time we've done one of
these on the street this is fun I know
it'll get more refined more
opportunities we get I'm just proud of
us doing my best here but uh but yeah
guys leave us your thoughts have you
seen Transformers rise of the beasts did
you go on IMAX what did you think and uh
yeah we'll catch you on the next one
don't forget to leave a like thank you
again to IMAX be well people reject
Nation roll out
[Music]